The second possibility, the second strategy was Distributed Responsibility.
The ScrollBar receives the change requests and determines the new value, that,
that is the relative, relative position in the ScrollBar tray.
It also knows that the ViewPort depends on this information, so
it makes a method call passing the relative position to the ViewPort.
The ViewPort compares the relative position received to the current value
associated with the top displayed line, and realizes that it cannot
satisfy the responsibility. It formulates a request to the FileManager for
the additional lines. The FileManager component returns the lines to
the ViewPort for display, thereby reestablishing the invariant. That is,
Knowledge of the invariant is distributed among three components that
delegate partial responsibility to each other when needed.